pensez depuis plusieurs années le centre
de ressources et d'interprétation de
port royal voit enfin le jour un lieu
paisible au coeur du site de port royal
des champs comme une invitation au livre
d'abord on s'adresse aux enfants
fréquentant du musée aux personnes qui
viennent visiter le lieu cet apport
l'objectif on vient accompagner répondre
à des intérêts de lecture en début ou en
fin de visite sur ça peut être sûr
champaigne ça peut être sûr peut-être la
prochaine exposition restos qui se
prépare dans le salon de lecture trois
mille volumes sont consultables sur
place parmi les thématiques abordées le
jansénisme et plus largement l'histoire
de france et le xviie siècle quant à
blaise pascal et jean racine figure
référente de port-royal leur ouvrage
occupe une place privilégiée
si le centre de ressources se tournent
principalement vers les chercheurs il
compte beaucoup sur les étudiants de
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines le son de ressources sont ni
accès avec le hall d'entrée parc et on
va on a créé une carte d'électeur listes
d'électeurs qui permet d'avoir un accès
libre ensuite facilité forcément à
partir d'une régularité de fréquentation
à chaque saison des visites thématiques
sont proposées au public pour échanger
sur l'histoire de port royal prochain
rendez vous hivernal sommes 12 janvier
autour des artisans de l'histoire